[Musique]
c'est à saint pierre que le président du
département le maire de la commune et la
vice-présidente du ccas signe la
première convention liées au pacte de
solidarité territoriale
un dispositif des aides en faveur des
communes que propose le département
l'objectif est d'accompagner le
développement des territoires à la fois
dans le domaine économique et social
aller vers le renfoncement de
l'épanouissement humain il faut avoir
des équipements de qualité dans les
quartiers et pas vous réalisez un petit
terrain de football aux biens d
équipement comme une bibliothèque ou
alors un centre d'animation est sans
accueil pour les gramounes mais ce sont
des équipements de proximité qui sont
très utiles et qui favorise comme vous
le dites l'épanouissement humain le lien
social
mieux vivre ensemble et la promotion
l'épanouissement des hommes et des
femmes de la réunion cesserait de belles
ambitions et nous portons cette ambition
avec les maires à travers le pacte de
solidarité territoriale la commune de
saint-pierre bénéficiera d'une enveloppe
de 4,6 millions d'euros pour la
réalisation d'une quinzaine de projets
et d'aménagement de proximité je prends
un exemple terrain synthétique
berry alex avec eux
cartier ou aides aux associations qui
oeuvrent dans le domaine par exemple de
l'aide aux sans domicile fixe ou pas mal
de choses qui nécessitent véritablement
d être rapide pour que lier des projets
qui sortent rapidement
neuf cent mille euros seront également
attribués au centre communal d'action
sociale de saint pierre où deux
personnes sont en précarité et on est
obligé de leur venir en aide
donc tout ce pacte social ça valait
beaucoup sur les familles en précarité
sur la réhabilitation de l'habitat et je
crois que c'est toutes ces familles
précaires qu'on va dans un premier temps
orientée 7 sont là le pacte de
solidarité territoriale en faveur des
communes représentent une enveloppe
globale de 90 millions d'euros
disponibles sur trois années cette
enveloppe comporte un volet
investissement de 75 millions d'euros et
un volet social pour un budget
prévisionnel de 15 millions d'euros
[Musique]